je suis fier de porter ce que certains
considèrent comme une utopie
parce que les utopies sont ce qu'ils
changent notre monde
le vote des femmes
la fin de l' esclavage des congés payés
était un jour des utopies qui sont
aujourd'hui des réalités
grâce à des gens comme vous et moi
moi aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
ces prochaines utopie qui pourrait
transformer notre société
le revenu de base inconditionnel
alors le revenu de base inconditionnel
c'est un revenu que recevrait toutes
personnes chaque mois sans condition et
qui permet d'assurer ses besoins de base
c'est un droit universel chaque être
humain le reçoit c'est un droit
individuel chaque personne reçoit le
même montant c'est un revenu que l'on
reçoit sans condition pas besoin de
remplir des papiers de faire de longues
queues de chercher un emploi
pour y avoir droit et c'est un revenu
qui permet d'assurer la base et auxquels
peuvent s'ajouter d'autres revenus donc
là en général quand on a dit ça les gens
trouvent que c'est une bonne idée mais
il ya une petite question qui se pose
c'est comment est ce qu on le finance
alors moi j'ai une autre question c'est
est-ce que aujourd'hui dans une société
comme la nôtre il est possible que
chacun de nous et de quoi se nourrir et
se loger
en fait ce revenu qui permet d'assurer
nos besoins de base nous l'avons déjà
sous forme de revenus d'activité de
revenus transfert d'allocations donc
avoir un revenu de base inconditionnel
c'est simplement simplifiée et
réorganiser l'existant je vais prendre
l'exemple de la suisse qui est celui que
je connais mieux puisque c'est là où je
m'engage pour le revenu de base donc en
suisse on parle d'un revenu de base de
2500 francs par mois par personne c'est
juste au dessus du seuil de pauvreté
financer ce revenu de base pour 8
millions de citoyens qui vivent en
suisse
ça représente 200 milliards par an 200
milliards c'est un tiers du pib
donc ça paraît beaucoup mais en fait ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que ce
revenu de base et ses 200 milliards sont
pas complètement à financer puisqu'ils
vont puisque leur ville basse à
remplacer une grande partie des
dispositifs existants aujourd'hui donc
par exemple en suisse il remplacera
l'aide sociale une partie des
allocations chômage une partie de la
retraite
une partie des revenus d'activité ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui déjà on pourrait le
financer si on le voulait c'est valable
pour la suisse mais c'est valable pour
d'autres pays comme la france
et comme plein d'autres endroits
simplement
chaque pays doit trouver sa manière à
lui d'ajuster par rapport à l'existant
aujourd'hui donc quand on a dit que
c'est finançable
il ya une deuxième grande question c'est
mais en fait si on donne de l'argent
comme ça chaque mois aux gens est-ce
qu'ils vont continuer de travailler
est-ce qu'ils vont continuer d'être
actif vous par exemple si vous aviez un
revenu de base ce que vous auriez encore
une raison de vous lever le matin
oui non en fait leur nid base il a été
testé dans différents endroits du monde
par exemple au canada dans les années 70
est ce qu'on a observé donc dans deux
villes du canada pendant plusieurs
années a été introduit un revenu de base
est ce qu'on a observé c'est que les
gens continuent à travailler autant
seuls deux populations travailler moins
des femmes qui venaient d'avoir un
enfant il pouvait ainsi se payer un
congé maternité et des étudiants qui
pouvait prolonger et terminer leurs
études en 2008
en namibie un contexte différent
une autre expérimentation du revenu de
base est là ce qu'on a observé c'est que
les gens travaillaient plus parce qu'en
fait le revenu de base constitué un
socle qui leur permettait de créer leur
activité et d'investir lire les
activités auto-entreprenariat elles se
sont développées de 300%
les revenus ont augmenté de 29% en plus
du revenu de base
ça me donne une petite idée que ce
revenu de base c'est pas juste un revenu
pour les feignants c'est un revenu en
fait qui nous permet de choisir ce qui
est important et d'y aller c'est un
revenu qui nous permet de faire des
choix à tous les moments de notre vie
choix de changer de carrière de se
former de s'occuper de ses enfants de
s'occuper d'un parent âgé de s'engager
dans des activités citoyennes comme je
le fais aujourd'hui
dans différents pays
la population se met à soutenir très
fort ce revenu de base
un sondage en france nous a dit que 60%
des français soutiennent le revenu de
base
je sais pas combien y en a dans cette
salle en finlande c'est encore plus ses
79 pour cent soixante dix-neuf en
français et en suisse où je vis d'où le
nous avons lancé en 2012 une initiative
citoyenne pour introduire dans la
constitution physique dans la
constitution suisse un revenu de base
nous avons récolté plus de 125 mille
signatures et ça veut dire que l'an
prochain nous allons pouvoir voter pour
décider si oui ou non nous voulons
introduire ce revenu bas dans la
constitution suisse j'espère qu'on
votera à la hauteur de vos
applaudissements
oui et souvent les gouvernements sont un
petit peu plus frileux que leur
population pour décider d'introduire un
revenu de base mais pourtant deux
gouvernements aujourd'hui s'engage deux
pays font le pas la hollande et la
finlande
donc la hollande dès 2016 30 villes vont
expérimenter le revenu de base et en
finlande dès 2017
ce sera une expérimentation qui aura
lieu dans tout le pays
et en fait je me dis que peut-être ces
deux pays sont juste un petit peu plus
consciente les autres qu'aujourd'hui on
a réellement besoin de ce revenu de base
depuis les années 1970
les gains de productivité ont beaucoup
augmenté le chômage également
et aujourd'hui cette tendance s'accélère
la robotisation l'automatisation la
numérisation font que des emplois
disparaissent
une étude récente de l'université
d'oxford nous dit que 47 % des emplois
sont automatisables aux états unis d'ici
une étude similaire rapportée à la
france nous dit que 42% des jobs sont
automatisables d'ici 2025
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup et ça
concerne chacun d'entre nous parce que
les emplois qui sont aujourd'hui
remplacés à la différence d'hier sont
des emplois qui sont dans le domaine du
service sont des emplois par exemple
traducteur journaliste banquiers parce
qu'une partie de ces métiers sont
automatisables par contre les métiers
qui sont plus créatifs
je sais pas par exemple publicitaires ou
bien des métiers de l'humain enseignants
infirmières ont moins de chance d'être
automatisés parce que les robots ne sont
pas encore réellement empathique
je pense qu'ils y travaillent mais c'est
plus compliqué oui et beaucoup donc de
nouveau de nouveaux emplois vont
apparaître pour remplacer mais ils ne
suffiront pas en fait à remplacer ceux
qui disparaissent
aujourd'hui on est dans cette époque
formidable
ou le salariat est en train de
disparaître
le travail à la tâche travail par
projets se développent chacun de nous au
cours de sa vie aura plusieurs métiers
souvent c'est déjà le cas et pour faire
que cette transformation cette évolution
ne soit pas une précarisation du plus
grand nombre
il faudrait que le progrès technologique
que nous connaissons s'accompagne d'un
progrès social d'une innovation sociale
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui notre
protection sociale a besoin de changer
d'évoluer de s'adapter au monde dans
lequel nous vivons et ce revenu de base
que certains considèrent encore
aujourd'hui comme une utopie ou un luxe
sera réellement demain une nécessité
merci